how's it going everybody it's Warren
it's a super exciting time right now for
Marvel fans we have phase four coming up
that we're getting a ton of information
about we had the Morbius trailer drop
yesterday and we got a special look at
Black Widow where we saw her and
taskmaster finally fight against one
another I'll link that up above if you
have not seen it yet but today we got
some new information about Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness we
got a new plot synopsis that actually
reveals quite a lot about the film so if
you're new be sure to subscribe and hit
the notifications bell so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU so recently a casting website for
actors searching for roles posted a plot
synopsis for actors looking for those
roles about certain movies and one of
them was Doctor Strange the plot
synopsis for Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness reads as follows
after the events of Avengers endgame dr.
Stephen strain continues his research on
the time stone but an old friend turned
enemy puts an end to his plans and
causes strange to unleash unspeakable
evil so there are a few things here in
the plot synopsis that are of great
importance one of course is the return
of the Infinity stones the plot synopsis
says that Doctor Strange is going to
continue his research on the time stone
this is something that he was doing in
the first Doctor Strange film and this
led him to ultimately defeat or at least
trap Dormammu so it looks like he'll be
picking back up his research and
multiverse of madness but that means
that the time stone and the Infinity
stones have to return this is not
impossible especially for the master of
the mystic arts and let's not forget
what the Russo brothers said about the
Infinity stones being reduced to atoms
they said that the Infinity stones
aren't gone they said that they were
simply reduced to atoms implying that
they could be reformed and if anybody
knows how to take an infinity stone at
an atomic level and reform it into an
actual stone its dr. strange and it
makes sense that he would reform it
because as we know the time stone was
the only thing keeping Dormammu from
returning without the time stone
Dormammu returns and not to mention that
the ancient one and Avengers in game
said that if you take even just one of
them away the whole reality is in
jeopardy and as we know from Avengers
infinity war it is dr. Strange's job to
protect this reality so it seems like
dr. strange is going to restore
Infinity stones he's then going to
continue his research but then an old
friend turned enemy is going to show up
and of course we all know who that is
Baron Mordo at the end of Doctor Strange
mortal was set up to be a future villain
Mordo and strange disagreed about how to
protect earth and the last time that we
saw Mordo he was killing another
sorcerer so the fact that he's going to
reappear in multiverse of madness makes
perfect sense especially after the
events of Avengers infinity war and
avengers endgame but as far as Doctor
Strange unleashing unspeakable evil is
concerned this could mean a couple of
different things one we know that
nightmare is supposed to be the main
villain of multiverse of madness the
unspeakable evil that is referred to
here could be about nightmare himself
multiverse of madness was originally
supposed to be a type of MCU horror film
now that scott derrickson is out of the
picture it may not be so much but Kevin
Feige has even stated himself that there
are going to be some horror aspects to
it and nightmares the perfect candidate
to bring some horror into this movie but
another threat that could be coming who
has actually been rumored to come as
Shuma gorath Shima gorath actually fits
pretty well for a couple of different
reasons one is that shuma girth is
originally banished to a different
dimension by a time-traveling sorceress
ice neg and clearly there's a connection
here with the time stone and time-travel
and another connection to multiverse of
madness is simply because Shima gorath
is from another dimension now we know
that multiverse of madness is going to
open up multiple different dimensions
multiple different realities and
universes that's why it's called the
multiverse of madness so perhaps somehow
while Doctor Strange is working with the
time stone he manages to open up all of
these different realities and the threat
of shuma gorath becomes very real for
his current reality
either way this plot synopsis does
confirm the return of the time stone the
return of Baron Mordo and something very
evil is coming to dr. strange so what do
you think about this new plot synopsis
what do you think about the Infinity
stones returning let me know how you
feel about this and the comments down
below also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe when notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything we're lightening to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win two Xbox one or ps4 the
winner is chosen at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof